you guys actually did a a skit with
Taylor Swift a while back how was that
what was that experience like we did it
was insane it was like our fourth week
or something working at SNL and we did a
video with Pete Davidson and Taylor
Swift called three sad virgins where
they're pretty much roasting us to
and calling us three sad virgins and
then we did a video with Travis Kelce
where he was beating the out of us
yeah so actually two pleas destroy a lum
yeah in the PDD Cinematic Universe the
hot couple has both really roasted
us was was she uh what was your
expectations before you started working
with her and then what was she like when
you guys actually did the skit together
what was that like Ben oh we pitched her
the song and we were like I certainly
there is no way she's going to do it cuz
she wasn't hosting she was just musical
guest and sometimes the musical guests
will do a skit sometimes they won't yeah
but we recorded this full de for her
with our friend Dan bullah and I'm
pretty sure it was himself singing her
part and he tried to do it like in the
same key he like listened to her album
over and over and tried to do it in the
same key and everything to to give her
like a fully polished demo version and
she listened to it and was like yeah
that's really funny I would love to yeah
and we were
shocked